まずられてるわけじゃないんですよいやほんとそうないいよ
本当の道先につけその合わせていっぱいばズレ待ちください
ジャズリストです
家の鍵がー
本当になくなっ
家の鍵が本当になくなりました吸ってるんです皆さん来なくずっと
ほぼほぼ100%帰ってくるのは何でも財布もそうねそう
176万円落車としも帰ってくるほどのその持ってる男なんですけど
パーッ今回は本当にないんですよ
はぁっ本当に個性だ方へちゃいますよじゃいつもの廃人ですよちなみにあの今僕が一気
してにはこのはじめミューズベッドパークと3号室隣の部屋だけなんですけどなんかし
た原因としては声聞いてさを変えますでずっとこの歌ちゃんが付いてたんですけども
要するにかけといえば2を探せばいいみたいな固定概念が僕の頭にあって蓋をとっ
またほど塗ってこれがカギだと思い込んでて来て鍵あるあると思ってるですけど全く別
のとこで鍵が移動して気づいたらなくなっていたというすべての影を失いました
車部屋部屋
[音楽]
バイクすべてのか業者だったので僕には今開けることができる
ドアが一つもありません強み果て下の民なんとかがいろんな高精度も使って全力で探し
たんですけども聞く見つかっておやつちょっと入って落ち着いて本気で探してみようと
思いますで鍵を失くす方よくいらっしゃると思うんですけども
探し物を見つける効果的な方法中というものを見つけました
これはちょっとステップで
やっていきましょーへとまず1まず落ち着く
すぷらっはぁっ
溺れたええええわっての裏だ落ち使ってアブつか落ち全然一番選手べきこと落ち着く
ことですない
ないパニックになっていた見つかるものを見つからないのです
ストレージがかかると人はきっとワーク何考えられない愚かな意思決定をしてしまい
ますと
十分写っこれ普通といけないとしたらもうちょい焦るやってるわーユーザーくるとん
そりゃ
冷感クールに俺待ってたから大丈夫これはに頭の中をクリアにする
同じじゃんコレ深呼吸をしたらとりあえず頭の中を空っぽにしてください
雑念がいっぱいだと探し物を見つけることに動かす出来ません当ててもものを当ててこ
ないのです者さん最後にそれを使ったのはいつか思い出す
てがもう3日目だけじゃなくなったのかわかんないよねこれは無理です皆
聞いても最後に見たのはこの作って言ってる人が多いんですけど
俺もここ行ったなって思ってせだした時に始めたからアートに行っちゃったのかなって
いうのはすごい確かめっちゃとっていくのかこのと神様になる
やばい頭が冴えてきてる目視では確認できんなん
今のところこっちのぬ
ないっぽいないなぜ25スターになる可能性もあるよまん
それありそうな場所リストアップ5リスタートできるというかもう全部晒せばいいと
思ってるんでリスタートする必要がないと思いますごありそうな場所順番に落ち着いて
探す enjoy まにょ人ぐらい人手がいるんでみんなでさんしていきましょうって
探すときは偏見を持たないここにある貨物って例えば捏ねるにあったからつっ
この前にばっかり探していると他の実が行かなくなるので全部とりあえずいてすべての
場所を均等に探すのがポイントらしいですな
ありそうにないけれど可能性としてあるかもしれない場所を探す人は覚え違いをします
いつも置かない場所に置いたかもしれませんおかなそうな場所を探しちゃっていいかな
と思いますで8番他の人が持っているのではないか
いや
疑ってるっていうわけなんですけどちょっと確認という意味で他の人が持っている可能
性も探していいかもしれません9番休息をとりのを休める
聖獣それでも見つからなかった場合 down sally のでは大衆的にはもう
諦めて
限る以上10点でございますでは早速探していきましょうよ
行くぞ
ん
re の
持っています
ええええええ
th
dj
[音楽]
me
の
ええええええ
ていた
[音楽]
しかし方がいい
颯一
サクサクコクヨフ
tee
ここ偽りのもここはかなり濃厚な方が感じます
お前この辺にある掛け算の声で
本気で探せ
しています
tt ああ
[音楽]
ました
ねーなー
ここがうごめきのマカ
[音楽]
この部屋からも濃厚なオーラを感じます
ああああああ
すべきだいじょぶっさああああああ
あああああっ
[音楽]
めーなー
ここは深淵のまま
たぶんこのようにある気がしますうんっ
ハーイ所バッハ
ああああああ
[音楽]
持った
うっ
売ってるんですねいや絶対はないんだけどこの揺られるバスに
絶対というにもじゃない
ています
いフェス済みすごいえっ4すごい
気持ち悪いです
ねこれ
ちょっとえっええっ
[拍手]
えええええええ
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
バッハ
どここの服の高2
ここにあったんだよ
ここにありました
車処方的じゃあまずいつかいやーすごいはイデホンということだねぇ
2日か3日9打差が生じたからねずっと探してた z だろそれじゃあもう歴史的瞬間
に立ち会いだと思うなぁあっ下さ落とし物は冷静に探すことが大事だということが
わかりますね
入っわけで今回の犯人はトランジスタでした俺えっ